but Richard now oh he's playing H he's
giv us something to yeah and now after
something like B B3 you might not even
get the position we were discussing you
might be in more trouble than you were
previously I think B B3 might might win
a piece yeah Bishop E3 just there's
Knight D6 so maybe Bish Bishop F4 maybe
to stop Knight D6 from happening and
then black position completely collapses
it feels like Knight takes F5 he's
reaching for the bishop Bishop he's
allowed Knight D6 which is
ah he has Rook C7 there it doesn't
matter has Rook C7 yeah nothing nothing
really matters
here um Rook C7 I thought I thought
bishop4 was a bit cleaner because we
don't want to be allowing Knight D6 at
all but it it shouldn't and it won't
matter exactly yeah and as you know and
there we have have it
wow congratulations is the sinkfield Cup
winner what a performance what a game he
actually broke a small little record
there has not been a decisive game in
the final round of the sinkfield since
2019 well 2023 right now
2023 with he broke a smile the very end
also if I have not misheard there was a
very interesting little tidbit uh in the
interview with Gary which kind of I
brings me uh to mind considering the
year that uh Fabby Fabi had I think Gary
said that that tournament in NS 991
where he actually remembered all the
last three opponents and the colors and
everything I was just standing there
thinking how right Ivan was leading I
had to play vishy I got luo in it's been
30 years how do you remember that I got
V but but then at the end he said I did
not catch up to ivanchuk and that was
the first tournament I didn't win since
1981 for 10 years and the the kind of a
dominant performance Fabi has had this
year sort of brings me uh reminds me of
the the best years of Gary when Gary was
a winning absolutely everything and our
congratulations absolutely he's won it
all and this year he became singfield
Cup champion Grand chor Champion St
Louis rapid and Blitz Champion I mean St
Louis is just his lucky place what a
performance as w Fields would say all
things considered I'd rather be in St
Louis I mean and a replay if you don't
mind me